[Musique]
prenez un conte piquer sans la pointe
sur une carte de paris entre le sacré
coeur et de moulin de la galette et des
filles déjà un cercle qui liera de la
place ravignan à la rue lamarck du
square saint pierre la rue qu'on a un
court vous aurez les frontières d'un
tout petit pays
montmartre
[Musique]
roland dorgelès dans le château
débrouillards a raconté ce montmartre en
partie disparu que l'on confond toujours
avec le montmartre dambach celui des
boîtes de nuit et des coiffeurs pour
dames séduit faivre peu d'honneur là
haut on se croit encore à la campagne
beaucoup de maisons ont leur bout de
jardin
[Musique]
et
fade magasins non plus qu'en ferait tant
dans un village juste ce qu'il faut de
boutiques pour rendre service aux
ménages
[Musique]
cette singulière paroisses vivent de
metz d'un côté de chansons de l'autre
est toujours le même objet de curiosité
sentimental rétro grade et piqué d'avant
garde avec de légers changements de
décors si léger à peu près imperméable
aux mots
magnifiques et charmant reposoir ou
pleurer ses souvenirs de jeunesse un
magnifique et charmant décor plein de
fumées légères pour y installer au
présent les aventures et les d'été de la
jeunesse de twitter
[Musique]
les amoureux mais bon vivant les
artistes les parisiens les provinciaux
les étrangers le nom d'ante il vient ici
retrouver ou découvrir une atmosphère
plus légère un certain art de vivre en
france heureux ceux qui seront saisis le
reconnaître et la pression
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le long de la rue saint-vincent que
chante à bruz en prêt de la vigne
célèbre est la maison de claude de la
rose dure aux imans comédiens de la
troupe de molière elle abrite
aujourd'hui la société d'histoire et
d'archéologie le vieux montmartre dont
nous parle son président monsieur gaston
leclerc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce musée est installé dans l'une des
plus anciennes maisons de montbard mais
en cas pas retenu un acteur de la troupe
de molière on est
nous exposons ici les envoie plusieurs
salles qui sont consacrés au fond de mon
mac la grande histoire la petite
histoire et les petites histoires de
montmartre c'est une exposition
permanente elles ont plusieurs salles
consacré les expositions temporaires
c'est ainsi que pour le moment nous
avons une exposition consacrée aux
grands artistes
montmartrois villette
la société d'histoire et d'archéologie
le vieux montmartre est la plus vieille
société d'archéologie de paris fondée en
1866 elle joint ses activités à celle du
centre culturel de montmartre et dans le
cadre de cette vieille et belle maison
au lieu des conférences très suis y
incite les expositions permanentes et
temporaires
actuellement c'est vilain qui est
présenté ici
[Musique]
villette fils de bateau tout de
fantaisie et de grâce artiste spontané à
l'imagination pétillantes comme le
champagne de sa région natale
n'acquittent à chalon en 1857 et mourut
à paris en 1926 son art est toute
jeunesse d'amour et de joie tantôt
poétiques ou rivoire drogués ou tantôt
tragiques plein de douceur et de
sarcasmes c'est à lui que l'hôtel de
ville demande à 1908 de donner vie aux
murs de la salle de la commission du
personnel il représenta bien sûr la rue
de berne
[Musique]
le musée permanent installé 17 rue
saint-vincent garde le témoignage des
plus émouvants moments du passé de
montmartre parmi les plus belles pièces
de ses collections admirons ces
magnifiques oeuvres de la porcelaine riz
de clignancourt fendait à montmartre en
1770 par le faire 2016 monsieur comtes
de provence
[Musique]
au hasard de la visite un monde de
souvenirs des affiches des statuts
[Musique]
ici celle de jules depaquit premier
maire de la commune libre de montmartre
et le zinc de l'abreuvoir ou bien des
verts furent vidés gaiement
[Musique]
une affiche de villette sur l'alcoolisme
l'esclave volontaire
[Musique]
le piano de paul d'elne et autres oumar
trois célèbres
[Musique]
chansons et
chinois une célèbre théâtre d'ombrés le
canada
[Musique]
pierre labrie mère international de la
commune les vieux montmartre depuis 1929
des 100 dit à bicyclette du premier
étage de la tour eiffel dessous d'un
loup 123
[Musique]
aristide bruant et la fiche de son
cabaret militons
des sols pleine de vie et de couleurs où
là il ne sait tous arrêtés à tendre et
amusé ou curieux
en l'honneur de ses beautés
santé
[Musique]
on peut découvrir ici la reproduction
fidèle du cabinet de travail de bus à
charpentier l'immortel auteur de loomis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'enseigne originale du célèbre lapin
agile du père freddy
[Musique]
nous possédons atteint paris un amour à
peu près inconnu malgré son nom illustre
et qui est la butte montmartre a écrit
pierre louiss en 1900 là haut c'est la
pleine campagne jardin murs décrépis
silence vol d'oiseau ceci est une icône
au montmartre est un hameau vers
assiégée par 40 centaine de milles être
humain il est à lui seul tout la paix
deschamps dominant la bataille des vues
nulle autre hameau n'est situé de la
sorte comme une île déserte au dessus
d'une tempête et nulle part ailleurs le
calme nulle part la solitude non par
opposition cette suprême valeur
[Musique]
oh
omar s'est amusé et mon mari c'est aussi
beaucoup de chansons tout le monde
connaît la complainte de la butte de
georges van parys
georges van parys nous a quittés
il demeure pourtant tellement présent
dans cette maison madame georges van
parys et bien voulu les siens entrer la
caméra de 8 bascoulergue
présent comme il l'est dans le coeur de
ses amis et dans la pensée de tous ceux
qui l'ont connu
c'est beau quelqu'un qui laisse un
pressoir des musiques vivantes et tant
de souvenirs chaleureux
[Musique]
jacqueline joubert vous aviez accueillis
dans une de vos émissions entre dans la
confidence une émission consacrée à cora
vaucaire vous aviez accueilli georges
van parys oui georges avait écrit le
portrait de gora vous savez qu'ils
étaient très amis il y avait une espèce
de parallélisme entre leur en france ce
que j'avais trouvé assez curieux ce que
je crois que george est aidé en bretagne
cora drive du enfin le contraire et
j'avais trouvé chez georges tout à fait
par hasard vous avez vu son but rose il
fait des choses extraordinaires de son
bureau a toujours l'air de la terre à
oui absolument clément et y avait des
photos de lui enfant alors qu'auriez
vous fait à ma place je vais demander la
permission de m'en servirai très
gentiment il a accepté et merci de nous
donner ces documents mais ce qui est
très troublant de voir à quel point
enfants il était le même à midi parce
que georges n'a jamais vieilli enfin je
parle de jargeau présent parce que pour
moi il n'est pas mort la mort n'existe
pas jean rouger et jeunes clj kg et
georgette avec nous voilà
je les ai rencontrés pour la première
fois
tiens ça commence comme une chanson
elle n'était ni corani vaucaire bien
vite nous sommes devenus des amis et
nous allions devenir encore bien plus
puisque cora devait épouser peu après le
mari de la soeur de ma farine cherchez
pas ce n'est pas un rébus b c'est la
stricte vérité
elle était un peu bretonne moi je suis
aussi breton mais un peu breton par mes
affinités
pourtant nous ne sommes pas de la même
mère la sienne c'est la manche quant à
la mienne c'est l'atlantique et puis ça
continue comme une chanson si nous
aimons tous de la mer nous avons aussi
de la mélodie
les collections de georges van parys
cora vaucaire je crois que ce sont des
collections d'objets qu'il aimait les
avez vu vous avez mis sa maison c'est à
dire tout ce qu'on imagine que quand on
parle de collection 10 des collections
inestimables et en fait c'est
inestimable c'est toute une vie d'amour
chaque objet est un élan une joie george
est un enfant à la découverte de chaque
chose alors c'est extraordinaire parce
que cette expression inestimable
il est toujours question d'argent mais
inestimable c'est de l'amour c'est du
coeur c'est tout ce qu'il a aimé toute
sa vie une affiche drôle à phonographe
un pavillon ou à rouleaux de un petit
personnage d'état un livre qui lui a plu
une lettre un manuscrit
d'une musique mais ça n'a pas de prix
c'est vrai parce que c'est tout tout
l'amour du monde et c'est une maison
vivent pas un décorateur roman je vais
me faire mal par des décorateurs ne peut
apporter
c'est qu'une personne comme genre qui
tout de même assez exceptionnel c'est
quelqu'un de tout à fait exceptionnel
tout la muse two l'ip lait dans la vie
j'ai vu georges écrire une partition de
films un opéra bouffe des chansons ses
mémoires s'occuper de la société des
auteurs de sa famille de ses enfants
tout le monde ses petits-enfants et les
maisons et ils avaient l'amour des
maisons et puis
la mer à la mer c'est fabuleux j'ai vu
georges arrivé au touquet courir mais
comme un tout petit enfant trop de la
mer et les larmes aux yeux
pour vous michel vaucaire georges van
parys était un musicien avec qui vous
allez travailler mais c'était aussi un
ami et même apparent oui nous avons été
beau frère pendant un certain nombre
d'années et alors il était toujours
resté et moralement et ami de jamie
depuis toujours 35 ans d'amis qui à peu
près si je vous demandais de me faire
son portrait c'est difficile vous l'avez
connu il était jeune il ça ressemblait
exactement
si je ferme les yeux et si j'essaie de
me remémorer la première image que j'ai
de lui et la dernière j'ai l'impression
qu'il n'ait pas changé et est ce que
c'était cette activité prodigieuse qui
lui donnait ce rayonnement j'ai toujours
vu pareil je ne pense pas qu'ils
puissent être passés il ya peut-être des
aides qui sont tous passés à la
naissance il ya des gens qui sont déjà
effacé qui n'existe jamais et à ce
qu'ils ne disparaissent pas quand on a
créé du bonheur quand on a créé de la
musique que dans la fête de la musique
dans sa vie et puis puis du bonheur
parce qu'on parle justement de cette
maison c'est du bonheur pour tout le
monde les jolis objets les objets qui
ont été choisis par le coeur il n'ya
que que de la joie que des élans le
musicien qu'est ce que vous pensez que
quel meilleur chez lui ce qu'il a fait
le meilleur c'est au percement que ses
opéras bouffe son centre est merveilleux
la tour eiffel qui tue est un
chef-d'oeuvre qu'il faudra reprendre qui
est qu'on avait donné peut-être 20 ans
trop tôt mais qui était il ya des choses
à viège programme et c'est pas de moi
y'a rien de moins c'est un job il ya des
airs éblouissant éblouissant de la
musique de georges est une chose
merveilleusement populaire et il a le
sens de la mélodie
ce qu'ils deviennent présent plus rare
parce qu'on peut devenir un musicien
très calé
et ne pas avoir le sens de la mélodie ça
c'est le don divin il avait une grande
facilité prodigieux soit unités et l on
pouvait lui donner des paroles et lui
dire écoute
j'ai besoin d'un musique pour demain bon
va bien prendre le café quo convient de
main la musique était fait de
l'accompagnement il n'y avait pas une
rature et au besoin il est même c'est
une petite orchestration temps je crois
que c'est dans le ton de la chanteuse
joss était prodigieux sa facilité
plusieurs vies il ya plusieurs vies
plusieurs donc les musiques tout ça est
plutôt bien qu'on retrouve george dans
un studio qui l'accompagnent petit
débutant georges qu'est ce que vous
faites là bas elle chantait une chanson
demain elle avait personne pour
l'accompagner alors il accompagnait sa
chanson bien sûr et puis les autres
puisque personne n'était là pour
accompagner leur type de 80 et puis
c'est comme ça qui m'a accompagné
petites débutantes et qu'il m'a dit ah
ça me rappelle la merveilleuse époque de
mes débuts quand j'accompagne yvonne
georges et comme il m'a beaucoup parlé
yvonne georges était très très fier il
accompagner votre ange il accompagner
votre georges il en parlait toujours
mais avec un bonheur inouï je veux dire
qu'on ne peut pas être accompagnées
mieux chez lui il était le plus souvent
à son piano à son bureau un soutien aux
caries foot il composait jetez pas ses
musiciens qui composent avec des
machines et reliques le jury composé
vraiment à son piano car il avait
commencé tout jeune comme enfant prodige
du piano il est important d'y rejouer
donné des concerts à 10 ans dans des les
petits cercles familiaux et
le quartier n'hésitez pas prodigieux
pianiste georges au piano toutes ses
chansons elle les connaît toutes celles
de ses films et où celle des autres
films qu'il n'a pas fait et puis des
chansons 1900 des chansons eu un sens et
sont illégaux
c'est vrai y est vous
le pire de tout ça c'est qu'on se dit
que ces foules tant qu'on peut perdre à
ne pas voir les gens qu'on aime puis
c'est très bête et vous a offert une
bien belle complainte de la butte
oui ça c'est toute une histoire et pour
moi c'est une espèce d'effectifs il
prétendait que c'était son son plus
grand succès de chansons
musicien curieux amoureux des choses
amoureux des objets amoureux de tout ce
qui est vivant excellente a ni
élégant il allait créer une bière jolies
choses dans dans son livre les gens
comme ils viennent mon fils m'a dit un
jour vraiment toi tu n'es pas mûres
c'est un compliment qu'il est allé droit
au coeur alors pourquoi serais-je assez
stupide pour me contraindre à renier
tout ce que j'aime sous le prétexte de
vouloir rester jeune aux yeux des autres
et non au mien non tout de même la vie
est trop courte
[Musique]
en haut de la rue saint vincent
a pointé une inconnue
et mr lesparre sénat l'instant
mais il ne l'a jamais revu
cette chanson il composa
respirant que sont inconnus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un matin de printemps
l'entendre en
quelques pas au coin d'une rue
[Musique]
la lune problème pose un dilemme
sur deux chevreaux
la lunette
de gloire éclabousse est au jupon
plateau
[Musique]
à lui n'étant pas le caresser le paul
dedieu blasé
[Musique]
princesse de la rue le soit la bienvenue
dans mon coeur blessé
[Musique]
la vue
romy
les loups des
la route est
[Musique]
petit mode ego plus juste on entame
notre qui cherche malin
[Musique]
je sens qu'à poitrine et vita taille fut
un jeu bly motion
[Musique]
de censure thales
preuve que l'odeur de fièvre de gosse
mal nourris
[Musique]
et suta carhaix
s'agissant unis rex qui m'a anéanti
les esprits
la vue
on me
[Musique]
d
la prothèse
amoureux
mais voilà qu'il flotte la lune c'est
rock la princesse aussi
que le ciel sans lune je pleure
alabrune
mon rêve
rêva
[Musique]